this is a place the United States has
been before one where hospitals are
pushed to the brink amid viral outbreaks
we're certainly seeing a lot of
infections of respiratory infections
that's not out of the normal heading
into the colder months
and in recent years the seasonal flu and
covid have resulted in a so-called twin
democ but now there's further pressure
due to a sudden increase in pediatric
RSV cases
two three times the volume we're seeing
in my just in my patient panel alone I'm
emitting one to two kids or more per
week which is not typical in an average
year 58 000 American kids are
hospitalized with the virus and 177 000
adults over 65 but covid might be making
things worse and turning this into a
triple demek we haven't had a lot of
respiratory illnesses for two and a half
years now people have maintained
physical distance people have worn masks
and that just keeps you from getting ill
and by not getting ill you don't develop
antibodies space to treat patients is
running out from Seattle to Washington
DC and Rhode Island 100 to 200 percent
plus of the beds are already in use in
some cases ventilator usage is also
Rising I think you're seeing a tidal
wave of uh sweeping across this country
right now RSV doesn't have a vaccine
leaving doctors and public health
officials to urge people to roll up a
sleeve that will keep people out of the
hospital prevent people from getting
seriously ill and its timing could be
essential the U.S flu season is already
ahead of schedule one-fifth of the
country is experiencing High activity
leaving healthcare workers to fear that
while it might not be as bad as in years
prior it is only going to get worse
Reggie kidney Global News Washington